I think it's a difficult question to
answer yes or no I think that the
question is more about it's not
necessarily about a specific country
where a specific solution will be found
to pour the world out of its global
economic crisis I think it's much more
about identifying an area or a theme
we're involved log in the renewable
energy and energy efficiency projects in
in China and I think that there is an
awful lot of opportunity for a growth in
the commercial components of transfer of
technology and I think that if we can
inspire technology transfer and then
have the correlation the correlative
effects of growth involved in
the overseas countries where the energy
where the technology is actually being
developed as well as growth of
Technology production in China and I
think that if we can grow that then it
will help to pull out the world out of
its economic crisis so I think it's been
lots of discussion about a green
revolution and a green revolution is not
just about saving the environment it's
also about economic opportunity and I
hope I very much hope that the world
begins to see that and people
particularly countries and commercial
industry begins to take advantage of it